遊戯王カードDIMENSION BOXっていうなんっか
なんかこう・・・なんか記念すべき遊戯王カードの販売日だったんですけど
めちゃくちゃ大変だった（泣）
めちゃくちゃ（大事なので二回言いました）
今日もうちょっとね遊戯王カードを買いにねもうほぼ徹夜で友達と買いに行ったんですけど
8店舗ぐらい行ったんですよ
静岡の店8店舗ぐらい行ったんですけど
一切なし
即売り切れで買えなくて
で、何だろう2,3店舗ぐらいかな
2,3店舗・・・？
・・・もう
もう静岡中の店今日朝から回ってもう一日中
遊戯王カード探してたんで
気付いたらこんな時間になってて
今日は・・・
・・・いやテキトーではないんですけどね、テキトーではないんですけど
そういう今日は時間がないので
まあタイトルにある通り
質問を募集させていただきます
いや申し訳ない、けど
ここで見栄を張っても仕方ない
もう正直に言います
今日は
遊戯王カードを買いに行って一日が終わってしまいました
悔いはありません（ｷﾘｯ）
というわけで質問コーナーの募集でございます
本当皆様の
良い・・・良くも悪くも
よ、良い質問のおかげで
なんとか質問コーナーとても皆さん楽しく見ていただけるようで
嬉しいんですけども
なかなか時間かかるので今回はちょっと余裕
んん・・・髪型がやだな
今回も多分時間がかかると思うので
余裕を持たせて告知させていただきます
そうだな・・・
最近Youtubeのコメントで多かったので
今日は・・・今日はっていうか今回は
というわけで今回の質問コーナーはTwitterからの募集になります
やべぇ・・・
遊戯王カードしてぇ＼(^o^)／
今日は11月26日
もうクリスマスまで一ヶ月後じゃねぇか＼ﾊﾟﾝ／
募集期間は動画上がった今日この日から
・・・とさせていただきます
僕頑張ってサーチするんでそれからなんかこう
お？お？お？？？？？みたいなヤツを選ぶんで
質問コーナーにします
多分ね・・・
クリスマスあたりをめがけていくと思いますよ
ハイというわけで今回の質問はクリスマスが
近い質問コーナーです
ね、結構余裕もってて12月11日までなんですけども
このコメント欄じゃないですよ
このコメント欄じゃないんですけど
今回の質問コーナーはＴｗｉｔｔｅｒでツイートしてください
あ、@hajimesyachoはつけなくて
いいですヽ(^q^)丿
えっと僕に質問したいこと
もう質問コーナーじゃないべ！！
もう質問コーナーじゃないもう質問コーナーじゃない
リクエストコーナーだ☆
分かりやすいんで質問コーナーって言いますけど
まあリクエストしたいこと
質問コーナー
は、やめましょう（皆守ろうね♡）
いや・・もういやもう何でもいい
もう何でもいい
なんかもうテキトーにあいうえおでもいいよ、もう（？）
もう何でもいいです
もうﾋﾟｰｰｰ（自重）とかでもぜn・・・
・・・あ、ダメだ・・・それはやめてくれ
それはやめてほしい
それだけはやめてくれ（懇願）
誹謗中傷以外でよろしく頼むよ
ほんと何でもいいので思ったことをTwitterで呟いてください
で、なんか僕に言いたいことをこうバッて書いた後に
下にハッシュタグをつけてください（ﾄﾞｰﾝ）
#おいこらはじめしゃちょーにしましょう
・・・うんいいと思うｗ
#おいこらはじめしゃちょーを最後につけてツイートしたら
僕がね検索してすぐ見つけやすくなるので
是非そちらを載せて僕に質問を出してください
・・・もうだめだ疲れた今日
ちょっとね・・・寝ずに遊戯王カードを買いに行くのはほんとにしんどかった
遊戯王やってる皆さん買いましたか？
僕の周りでも買えない人が続出してますよ・・・
ちょっと今日は遊戯王店に出させていただいた・・
・・・あぁ明日東京じゃん！！！
明日TOKYOだ～～(><)
ハイ、というわけでちょっとねまたバタバタしますので今日はね
質問コーナー募集でございます
是非みなさん
何でも聞きたいこと是非是非かいてください
では質問コーナー是非クリスマス近くにお会いしましょう
ぉいじゃあ今日のセカンドじゃあ・・本物だった
じゃあな！！
さて問題です
はじめんはこの動画で何回遊戯王と言ったでしょうか？
thinking time...
正解は・・・
9回でした☆